good afternoon I'm Matthew Spalding
associate vice president and Dean fields
of college here in Washington DC
welcome to hills of colleges Washington
campus we have a very interesting talk
for you the the the this afternoon and
I've been talking with the author I look
forward to hearing from him Hillsdale
College generally follows back here in
Washington's and changes going on in our
culture and political life of our nation
and we have watched recently as Michigan
the state were also colleges based has
become the tenth state to legalize
marijuana others will soon follow there
seems to be a strong trend towards
legalization but one wonders whether
we've gotten ahead of the science or at
least ahead of ourselves
when it comes to safety and public
health and our speaker has written a
book that goes the the the arguments and
truths about marijuana when it comes to
those questions and things are not
currently being discussed and debated
Alex Berenson is a former New York Times
reporter and award-winning novelist he's
graduating University with recent
history and economics began his career
in journalism in 1994 as a business
reporter for the Denver Post joined the
financial news website the street in
1996 and worked as an investigative
reporter for the New York Times from
1999 to 2010 during which time he
covered a lot of different things from
Hurricane Katrina to the drug industry
and also served as a war correspondent
in Iraq in 2006 because of that
experience he wrote his first novel the
faithful spy which won the Edgar Award
from the Mystery Writers of America for
best first novel and he's written ten
novels since that's 12 novels since and
two non-fiction books the first called
the number how the dryer for quarterly
earnings corrupted Wall Street in
corporate America and now his most
recent book tell your children the truth
about marijuana mental illness and
violence out from Free Press Alec's
parents
[Applause]
so first of all thank you to Matthew
thank you to Matt Bell for setting this
up to Adel for helping with logistics
and to everybody at Hillsdale and Kirby
for having me you were the first big
group to ask me to come speak about this
book but it seems like you will not be
the last the the Florida Legislature has
asked me to talk the government of
Singapore wants to have a conversation
I'm not sure why and there's some other
people so so the book has gotten a lot
of attention since it came out in the
last week and I'm really happy about
that not because I want to I really
actually don't want to be on the
forefront of this issue but because I
think this this book contains a lot of
facts that people need to know
especially parents of teenagers and
young adults and especially young adults
themselves because I do think that the
the science around marijuana and
psychosis has basically been lost in the
last few years which is probably not a
coincidence there's been a lot of work
done by advocacy groups cannabis
advocacy groups to make that happen so
let me let me give you my speech which
is a version of the an excerpt that Hill
stones gonna run and impress this this
month and then I'll happily take as many
questions as you have I assure you I can
for you to tears with the science around
this if you want but all throwing some
true crime to if you like so everyone
stays awake so 70 miles northeast of New
York City is a hospital that looks like
a prison
it's drab brick buildings wrapped in
layers of fencing and barbed wire this
grim facility is called the New Year is
called the mid-hudson forensic
Psychiatric Institute it's one of three
places the state of New York sends the
criminally mentally ill that is
defendants or judge not guilty by reason
of insanity which technically in New
York State is
reason of mental disease or defect but
most people call it ng RI not guilty by
reason of insanity until recently my
wife Jackie dr. Jacqueline Berenson was
a senior psychiatrist there many of mid
Hudson's 300 patients are killers and
arsonists at least one is a cannibal
most have been diagnosed with psychotic
disorders like schizophrenia that
provoked them to violence against family
members or strangers a couple of years
ago Jackie was telling me about a
patient in passing she said something
like well of course he'd been smoking
pot his whole life of course I said I
was pretty skeptical she said yes they
all smoked I said really she said really
I said so marijuana causes schizophrenia
she said yes it does I was surprised to
say the least I tended to be a
libertarian on drugs I figured people
ought to make their own mistakes years
before I'd cover the pharmaceutical
industry for The New York Times and I
was aware of the claims that advocates
had made about marijuana as medicine and
I was aware that all of us sir I was are
vaguely aware that a lot of those seem
to be overstated but I'd watched the
slow spread of legalized cannabis you
know beginning in Colorado in Washington
and now in ten states plus medical
marijuana without too much interest well
my wife wouldn't have been well within
her rights to say I know what I'm
talking about
unlike you maybe you should stop
mansplaining
but she didn't she said something like
well yeah I think that's what the big
studies say maybe you ought to read them
so I went back to my roots as a
journalist and and I read those studies
I read the big ones I read the little
ones I read basically all of them I
could find and I talked to all the
psychiatrists and all the brain
scientists who would talk to me and
who'd been doing research on this and
and turns out there's actually a lot of
them and I soon realized that in all my
years as a journalist I had never seen a
story where the gap between insider and
outsider knowledge was so big or where
the stakes were so high you know as an
investigative reporter you look for a
few things in determining what stories
you should try to chase
one is whether other people are chasing
it because to the extent you have
something that other people are not
thinking about it's you're more likely
to be able to make progress on it
without having to overstate what you're
doing another is the the public health
impacts the societal impacts or public
health of the story that you're working
on another is if it's counterintuitive I
mean if I told you that heroin was
dangerous that would not be a big
surprise but I don't think a lot of
people know this and and and the fourth
is sir it's sort of the overall impact
you might have and so and so this story
seemed to hit all of those bells in a
way that I hadn't seen you know
certainly since I had been at the Times
and I and I and I really did wonder what
what I might be missing so so over the
last 30 years psychiatrists and
epidemiologists have turned speculation
about marijuana's dangers into science
yet over the same period a shrewd and
expensive lobbying campaign has pushed
public attitudes towards marijuana
safety the other way and the effects are
now becoming apparent almost everything
that you think you know about the health
effects of cannabis almost everything
that advocates and the media have told
you for a generation he is wrong it's
either untrue or at best hugely
overstated
they've told you that marijuana has many
different medical uses in reality
marijuana and THC it's active ingredient
have been shown only to work in a few
narrow conditions they're most commonly
prescribed for pain pain relief but
they're rarely tested against other
active drugs like ibuprofen for pain and
in July of 2018 a large four-year study
of patients with chronic pain in
Australia showed that cannabis use was
actually associated with greater pain
all the time they've told you that
cannabis can help stem opioid use which
is obviously a major issue given the
opioid crisis in the United States
mainly the the argument goes like this
that that that for people who are using
opiates as a painkiller the the
pain-killing effects of cannabis might
be a substitute for opioids but the
truth
that unlike out that like alcohol which
is an intoxicant first and a pain
reliever second marijuana is too weak as
a painkiller to work for most people who
truly do need opioids such as terminal
cancer patients even cannabis advocates
like Rob Campea who co-founded the meta
the Marijuana Policy Project and who I
spoke to for the book acknowledged that
they've always used viewed medical
marijuana laws mostly as a way to
protect recreational users and the
marijuana reduces opioid use theories
based largely on a single paper came out
in 2014 that compared overdose deaths by
state before 2010 to the spread of
marijuana medical marijuana laws so when
you look in the you know 2000 through
2010 period and you say these states
legalized medical marijuana and which
states have the highest opioid use you
do find that states that legalize seem
to have lower opioid use and lower
increases in opioid use that is true but
the papers finding is largely is
probably a result of simple Geographic
coincidence the opioid epidemic began in
Appalachia
while the first states to legalize
medical marijuana were in the West since
2010 as the opioid epidemic has spread
nationally and medical marijuana laws
have jumped pretty much nationally the
finding has vanished and and what nobody
seems to have paid any attention to is
that the United States and Canada which
are the countries that have the most
opioid use also have by far the worst
problem with opioids I'm sorry also yes
they have the most cannabis use and the
most opioid use I'm sorry so when you
look at individuals when you look at you
know which is a better way to try to
track changes in behavior then then
looking at states because states can
change four things can happen in states
for a lot of different reasons the state
might you know it might suddenly have a
new prescription drug monitoring program
that strict that helps doctors monitor
opioid use by patients and that might
reduce state level use of opioids the
best way to track whether some things
affects an individual's behavior is to
look at individuals I mean the absolute
best ways to do what's called a
randomized controlled trial where you
take two groups you
try to make sure there is evenly matched
as possible and you give people one drug
and you give the other side no drug or a
different drug and you see how they
change then you can then you can say
with some certainty the drug caused the
changes now we can't do that with
marijuana because it's unethical to give
people a drug that might hurt them but
so instead we're sort of stuck with less
convincing data but the but better than
state-level data is to try to track a
bunch of individual users over time and
that research has been done and that
research consistently shows that
marijuana use leads to other drug use so
this is where the Gateway the Gateway
hypothesis comes from and there's a lot
of arguments about the Gateway
hypothesis not because people don't
agree that it that it's real everyone
agrees that it's really you can't look
at the data and not see that it's real
the argument on the legalization side is
hey marijuana it's marijuana is a
gateway because it's illegal so you have
to go to a dealer to get it that dealer
might be selling you opiates or cocaine
as well eventually you wind up using
those things and that's actually you
know if you if you view it that way as
an argument for legalization but but
that aside and the other argument is
that marijuana is an intoxicant that
gets people high and when people get
high they want to get high on other
drugs and so that marijuana sort of farm
pharmacologically Prime's the brain for
later use III would say that that debate
has not been settled but what is clear
is that there's no serious research that
says that marijuana use does not lead to
opioid use later when you look at
individuals so this this theory looking
at the state-level data is just not
supported by real evidence but people in
the cannabis community have really
pushed it and I think it's incredibly
dangerous which is why I spend time on
it in the book because I don't think
that we should be encouraging people who
are at high risk for addiction to use an
addictive and toxic and I think that's a
really stupid idea and I think and I
think we have a we have a real we have a
real duty to discourage that so that's
the opioid issue which is a little bit
off to the side of the main thrust of
the book most of all
advocates have told you that marijuana
is not just safe for people with
psychiatric problems like depression but
a potential treatment for those problems
on its website 'is a cannabis delivery
service and those do exist they're
advertised in California and other
states offers the best marijuana strains
and products for treating anxiety Leafly
the biggest cannabis website asks how
does cannabis help depression
unfortunately a mountain of
peer-reviewed research and top medical
journals shows that marijuana can cause
or worsen severe mental illness
especially psychosis psychosis is the
medical term for a break from reality
teenagers who spoke who smoke marijuana
regularly are about three times as
likely to develop schizophrenia the most
devastating psychotic disorder and that
doesn't come from me that comes from the
National Academy of Medicine the
federally chartered group that is that
is charged with providing unbiased
advice on medical and health issues
after an exhaustive review the Academy
found in 2017 that cannabis use is
likely to increase the risk of
developing schizophrenia other psychosis
and social anxiety disorders it also
reported that the higher the use the
greater the risk so that came out in
January 7 2017 and I think literally
nobody read it if you if you go back and
look at coverage of this exhaustive 500
page report that the National Academy of
Medicine put out there's essentially
none last year the New York Times ran a
very brief online article about it but
this I mean this came out this is you
know this is the this is the scientific
you know Advisory Committee to the
United States basically saying this
definitively and nobody pays any
attention
you know they've report on vaccines and
autism and those reports have gotten a
lot of attention this this vaccines and
autism are important a recreational drug
used by 40 million people having
potential psyche severe psychiatric
consequences to my mind is a lot more
important but it was simply ignored so
the higher the use the greater the risk
and in the last decade as legalization
has spread patterns of marijuana use and
the drug itself have changed in
dangerous ways legalization
hasn't actually led to an increase in
the number of people who use the drug
casually that's sort of surprised I'm
not a huge increase it's led to a
moderate increase about 25 million
Americans used casually in 2005 that was
10 percent of the population in 2017
about 40 million did that's about 15
percent in comparison about 170 million
Americans had a drink in 2014 so or in
2017 I'm sorry so so cannabis is still
not nearly as widely used as alcohol
it's still it's so basically that's
that's not quite a you know a
counterculture drug but it is not a
mainstream drug in the way that alcohol
is but all the people who used of those
40 million people eight million of them
used everyday in comparison so that's
one in five people who use use every day
in comparison about one in 15 or
drinkers drank every day 12 million
people drank every day eight million
people use marijuana every day marijuana
is a drug that when people use it if
they like it they tend to use a lot of
it because basically because it's not
physically damaging in the way that
heavy alcohol use is if you if you go to
bed drunk every night you're gonna wake
up knowing what you've done and unless
you are you are seriously committed to
drinking you know that's gonna that's
gonna kind of discourage you from doing
it but you can get high all day every
day and wake up feeling pretty much okay
physically the next day and you know and
that is why there is this there's this
prevalence towards heavy use at the same
time those people are consuming cannabis
far more potent than ever before as
measured by the amount of THC which is
the chemical in cannabis responsible for
its psychiatric effects that the drug
now contains in the 1970s the last time
the cannabis was this widely used in the
United States the drug was about 2% THC
you could get if you really wanted to
you could you could get some you know
sort of high-grade mexican pot that was
10% THC today if you go into a
dispensary in Colorado a legal
dispensary you will be presented with
cannabis that is 20 to 25 percent THC
you will have to ask for lower potency
significantly lower
see stuff and the there's also less of a
chemical called CBD in it which actually
counteracts the effects of THC so when
people say that cannabis is much more
potent than it used to be they're
they're not lying it's absolutely true
it's a scientific fact you know you sort
of should think about the difference
between drinking near beer and a martini
to understand the difference back in the
70s in the 80s you could smoke a lot you
could smoke enough pot to get high you
could certainly smoke enough pot to have
a you know to have a psychoactive impact
but you had to work at it you actually
did and now it's very very easy to do so
so what's happened we have more people
smoking stronger pot more often and
what's happened is that the new patterns
of use have caused problems with the
drug to soar so in 2014 which is the
most recent day a year for which data is
available about one and a half percent
of Americans had what was called
cannabis use disorder so that's what
psychiatrists call dependence or
addiction that's I'm trying to stop I
can't stop it's caused problems for me
you know when I try to quit I get
insomnia you know I'm having problems at
work because of this I'm having problems
with my kids or at home because of this
but I can't quit that's it that's that's
basically the the layman's definition of
you know abuse or dependence so one and
a half percent of Americans fit that
category but the number of people who
showed up in emergency rooms and were
diagnosed with psychosis that year was
about 800,000 and 90,000 of those people
had marijuana use disorder so in other
words one and a half percent of
Americans had marijuana used to serve
but 11 percent of the people who went to
ers with psychosis had problems with
marijuana widget but all by itself is a
gap that should make people pay
attention and you know in states like
Colorado people have had people who run
ers who run psychiatric emergency rooms
or even just regular emergency rooms
they've become experts in dealing with
cannabis psychosis and the effect is not
just confined to people who are breaking
down enough
to get to the emergency room once in a
while cannabis advocates often argue the
drug can't be as dangerous to the brain
as these individual studies suggest
because otherwise Western countries
would have seen population wide
increases it alongside rising use so in
others arugam is well we don't think
schizophrenia is increasing in the
United States and if if cannabis is
really that dangerous and so many people
are smoking it how come it hasn't gone
up but the truth is that accurately
tracking psychosis and schizophrenia is
it's basically impossible in the United
States I can tell you how many people
have cancer or got cancer last year in
the u.s. basically to the case we track
that we don't track cases of psychosis
or schizophrenia mental health
information is widely protectors is very
strongly protected and we don't even
make an effort to try to count cases in
countries where they do have some better
data and that includes the northern
European countries they now have seen an
increase at least in Denmark and Finland
in cases of Skype in cases of psychosis
in schizophrenia in the last 20 years
and those countries don't even have the
level of cannabis use that we do but
they have seen an increase in cannabis
use and now they're seeing what might be
population level effects and there's one
other bit of data which is that in 2017
whatever year the federal government
does a very big survey called the
national survey on drug use and health
they actually cover 70,000 people that
study in 2017 showed that seven and a
half people in the age range 18 to 25
young adults had serious mental illness
or met the criteria for serious mental
illness now that's that's obviously a
squishy number that's not people going
to the psychiatrist and being diagnosed
or even to a you know a family doctor
and be diagnosed it's based on surveys
but it is really the only number that we
have that number doubled since 2008 so
in 2008 about four percent of people in
that age range had serious mental
illness in 2017 the number went to 8%
nobody knows why but what is striking is
that people when older groups and people
younger groups didn't show the same rate
of increase and guess what the rate of
cannabis use is highest in that age
range so we have we we basically have a
lot of data that all points the same way
and when I was talking to Matthew before
the talk started I said look you can
explain away any one of these things in
fact you can explain what all of them
but somebody needs to show me some data
that isn't bad somebody needs to show me
some data that like that says that any
of the positive impacts of cannabis use
that were promised or even non negative
impacts are showing up in some data
because I can't find it and I've looked
so marijuana does cause psychosis it
certainly causes it temporarily and in
in in rare but but you know not in a
non-zero number of cases it causes
permanent schizophrenia that's certainly
what the best data suggest and what the
scientists have done the most research
on this agree and the downstream effect
is that psychosis causes violence and
and this is even this is not open for
debate okay we don't like to talk about
it it's a painful subject because
advocates for the mentally ill feel that
talking about the link between psychosis
and violence stigmatizes the mentally
ill but it is unquestionably true people
with schizophrenia are about twenty
times it's likely to commit homicides as
healthy people that is a that that
number comes off very good data forty
years of data between 1970 and 2010
across cultures across across nations
across races whatever your baseline rate
of homicide is having a psychotic
disorder increases it dramatically and I
think I think we all know this I think
when you see the person on the Metro
platform is talking himself you walk
away because you know that that person
is a danger you don't know how big a
danger but you know that person is a
danger and there's some also some very
interesting data showing that so in the
you know in the first half of the 20th
century people with severe mental
illness work basically institutionalized
permanently almost always and that's it
I'm not saying that we should go back to
that there were very severe problems
with that but perceptions of people with
mental illness as dangerous were not
nearly as high
then as they are now probably because a
lot of dangerous people were being taken
off the streets and locked away and so
when people say that talking about this
issue stigmatizes people with mental
illness that's unfortunately true but
it's the violence that people with
mental illness commit people with
psychosis I should say commit that
actually it's the problem that's what
leads to the stigma and even worse than
that is the fact that most of this
connection is mediated by illegal drug
use or not illegal but recreational drug
use so if you have mental illness and
this is true even if you have severe
mental illness even if you have
psychosis or schizophrenia if you are
taking your medicine if you are staying
staying off recreational drugs you are
not that much more violent than a
healthy person if you're if your mental
illness is being treated if you are not
you're not particularly violent it's
when you go off your meds and when you
start using recreational drugs that the
violence risk skyrockets and drug that
people use the most when they're
mentally ill is cannabis but
unfortunately because cannabis provokes
paranoia in some people that's a really
bad drug for them to use so so there's
this vicious cycle where people with
psychosis use the drug become paranoid
and in some cases commit terrible
violence and so I mean it's what's
interesting about this is that people
have known this for at least a hundred
years there's good data from British
asylums in India you know they were then
called insane asylums we now call them
psychiatric hospitals they every back
then the doctors who ran those who ran
those hospitals said that 20 to 30
percent of the cases of mental illness
that they saw and 20 to 30 percent of
the cases of criminal violence that they
saw came out of of cannabis use and it
was mostly stronger preparations it was
mostly well what basically a version of
what we call hashish and a version of
flower cannabis that wasn't as strong as
what people use now but it's still what
was still reasonably strong so are we
seeing any real world impact
from this before legalization began
recreational legalization began in 2000
and really in 2014 in Colorado and
Washington advocates said that
legalization would let police focus on
hardened criminals on murderers rapists
people committing assaults and
burglaries rather than marijuana smokers
it would reduce violent crime that said
it would also end the black market it
would reduce violent crime that way and
some advocates are still saying this
they're still saying that violent crime
has gone down in these states in fact in
a 2017 speech calling for a federal
legalization cory booker said that these
states are seeing decreases in violent
crime but that's just not true in the
four states that legalized first if you
compare the last full year pre
legalization which was 2013 to 2017
which is the year for which we have the
most recent data you see that murders
have increased 37 percent and aggravated
assaults have gone up 25 percent if you
combine the four states that's the
fullest data set now if you just for
population growth because those states
have increased in population a little
bit faster than the overall us the
differential goes down a little bit but
it's still true that the increase in
murders in those four states is about
double the overall us increase since
2013 now I looked at a lot of cases I
did not look at all 620 murders in
Colorado in 2017 so so knowing how much
of that increase might be related to
cannabis is impossible I mean you'd have
to literally research every crime and
you have to go back and research all the
crimes in 2013 and come upon some
agreed-upon waiting to to you know
associate a crime with marijuana use
versus not this is this is where it gets
very complicated but police reports news
stories and arrest warrants suggest a
close link in in case in some cases for
example on September 24th of 2018 police
in Longmont Colorado
arrested Daniel Lopez for stabbing his
brother Thomas to death as a neighbor
watched Daniel had been diagnosed with
schizophrenia and was self-medicating
with marijuana according to an arrest
affidavit that's that's just a classic
presentation I I
can I could give you dozens of similar
cases in these states and in every state
not just those where marijuana is legal
cases like Lopez are more common than
either cannabis or mental illness
advocates acknowledge cannabis is also
associated with a disturbing number of
child deaths from abuse and neglect many
more than alcohol and more than cocaine
methamphetamine and opioids combined
according to Texas which is one of the
few states to provide detailed detail on
drug use by perpetrators unfortunately
Colorado and Washington and the other
legalized states don't at least haven't
been able to find it so we don't have
that data from those states now for the
most part you've never heard of any of
these crimes they rarely received more
than local attention so he kosis there
first of all there was 18 thousand
murders in the United States every year
that's 50 a day so you're just not gonna
hear about all of them but psychosis
induced violence takes particularly ugly
forms and is frequently directed at
family members the media you know the
elite media the places like the New York
Times where I used to work doesn't want
to report on these cases they they you
know they're sort AB Lloyd fodder like
you might find them pop up in the New
York Post for a day if they're
particularly vicious and bloody but they
they go away pretty quickly and even
police departments which see this
violence of clothes have been slow to
recognize the trend in part because
they're facing this epidemic of opioid
deaths and that is you know public
health emergency number one which I
completely understand and so the black
tide of psychosis and the red tide of
violence are rising steadily on this on
this wave of cannabis use so 20 years
ago we decided that we would encourage
allow if not encourage wider use of too
big drugs slash drug categories cannabis
and opioids we decided that we were
smarter than these drugs that we knew
how to manage their risks that the risks
had been overstated that you know that
people could easily tolerate you know
really potent opioids for pain without
getting addicted that the risks of
cannabis had been overstated because of
the drug
you know the anti-drug lobby
you know that that that that reefer
madness was a joke and we decided you
know what we can we can we can we can
encourage wide societal use of these
drugs we can have their benefits their
pain-killing benefits you know of the
benefits of having an intoxicant without
their costs unfortunately we were wrong
there isn't a free lunch when it comes
to drugs whatever we decide to do we
need to stop pretending that cannabis is
a harmless substance whatever we
whatever we decide to do about
legalization we need to do that and you
know we focused on opiates for the last
10 to 15 years and that's totally
understandable because they kill people
very quickly and you know a half million
people have died from opiates in the
u.s. in the last 20 years and I fully
understand why that is where the
attention of public health experts has
been but the risks that cannabis prevent
present are real and I think that pretty
soon the the sort of the this the slow
rise in mental illness and violence is
going to become hard to ignore whether
whether you use cannabis or any drug is
your own decision and whether it should
be legal decriminalized or prohibited is
a political issue although we're not
gonna prohibit it 40 million people used
it that's you know that's in 2017 we're
not gonna put them all in jail we need
to decide what we are gonna do but the
legal status of cannabis is less
important than making sure that anyone
who uses it is aware of the risks most
cigarette smokers do not die of lung
cancer but we say that cigarettes cause
cancer
full-stop most people who drink and
drive don't have fatal accidents but
drinking and driving
drinking raises the risk substantially
for a road accident so we tell people
not to drink and drive and I would much
rather become sick with lung cancer at
age 60 from smoking cigarettes then
become psychotic at 25 from smoking
cannabis there's no question about that
I mean I you know even even though lung
cancer is a fatal disease schizophrenia
you know when I talk about the violence
its terror
but I don't want to forget schizophrenia
is a terrible disease for the people who
suffer psychosis is terrible it wrecks
people's lives it wrecks their families
most people who have it they don't get
married they don't have kids their lives
are just they're just not very good and
you know if we can prevent cases of that
we should try to do so so we need
pointed and well funding funded
advertising campaigns on the risks of
cannabis instead at this moment in the
United States we're in the worst of all
possible worlds we have the drug that's
legal in some states illegal and others
so you even have this black-market
between the states where it's legal in
the states where it isn't it's very
potent and it's sold without warnings
all over the you know everywhere but
before we can figure out how to talk to
people without this the advocates and
the people in the elite media who've
accepted the claims that this is a and
this is a harmless drug need to come to
the terms with the truth about the
science on cannabis and psychosis and
the truth about the science on psychosis
and violence and that's going to be
painful that's not a fun conversation to
have as I've learned in the last week
but but but the alternative is worse the
alternative you know as the people at
mid-hudson as the patients at MIT Hudson
can tell you it is much worse not to
have these conversations and to have the
identity you know that the side effects
that using this drug can cause so thank
you all I hope I hope that was
interesting and I'm glad to take
whatever questions you might have
[Applause]
oh sure and by that I have no idea
whether this will be a skeptical or a
friendly audience know what maybe some
of oh hi my name is charles lehman i'm a
writer with the washington free beacon I
cover drugs and drug policy from a data
focus perspective I have a little bit of
a technical question but I hope you'll
bear with me I won't talk too much um so
one of my concerns about the book is the
fact that you spend a lot of time
reporting relative effect sizes as
opposed to absolute effect sizes say
marijuana cop increases the risk
screening by two or three times looking
at the the first study that you cite the
Swedish study the name of which the
science that cannot pronounce because
I'm van Driessen san andreas look at the
injuries in study you say about half a
percent of the cohort that he cites in
Tooele schizophrenia subsequently 1% if
their marijuana exposed 2% if their
chronic marijuana users and the first
effect largely disappears with
controlling the second effect is about
halved those are those are the effect
sizes that have to go on I've looked at
some of the literature that you cited
but not all of it
and they said a lot of odds ratios - my
point is there are lots of risk factors
with schizophrenia family history
exposure to lead poverty whether or not
you owned a cat as a kid because that's
a vector for exposure to toxoplasmosis
condi I am totally convinced that
marijuana is one of many skits it was
one of many risk factors for chronic
teenage momona uses one of many risk
factors for schizophrenia there are lots
of those why is this one the one that
you chose to focus on and why is this so
substantial of a concern given its
comparatively minimal effect on the
overall instance right so that is that's
a totally reasonable question you know
the number that gets thrown around for
schizophrenia use in the worldwide is 1%
which sounds too round to be right and
probably is not right
it's probably about 0.7% it's a little
bit low or 0.5 to 0.7 percent and if we
want to be really conservative and say
that you know heavy canvas use doubles
that
it's probably somewhere between doubles
and triples but let's say doubles so
we're talking about one in 200 smokers
is gonna get you know somewhere between
1 and 151 and 200 smokers is going to
develop schizophrenia given the societal
personal costs of schizophrenia I think
that's a that's a discussion worth
having and I think that's actually a low
estimate I'm trying to be conservative
there's also temporary psychosis so
temporary psychosis
you know the cannabis can clearly cause
temporary psychosis and does in a lot of
people who who are health or you know
who are healthy who don't have risk
factors and those people sometimes come
in violence too so that's a secondary
basket and it's an arguably a bigger
basket now there's another way to look
at this which is you can sort of look at
diagnoseable psychosis on a population
basis which is not just schizophrenia
it's bipolar disorder with psychosis
depressive psychosis there's all these
other versions and the best numbers on
that are that's about 4% of the
population so now we're starting to get
to a you know a pretty significant
number now how much does cannabis use
drive that you know I think if you talk
to the epidemiologists you can get
they're guessing everyone is guessing
it's not gonna be more than 10% so how
much psychosis is okay I don't know
there are other mental health issues
related with marijuana but psychosis
drugs violence so to me that's the one
that I focused on in the book and when
you're talking about things like
depression or suicide
things that are very multifactorial and
usually been a drug that's used by a lot
of people who decide it's even more
complicated so so so I'm not saying that
you know we're gonna eliminate marijuana
and I'm not saying that we're gonna
eliminate psychosis and either those
things is true what I'm saying is that
the conversation around the benefits and
the risks of this drug have have been
ridiculously one-sided and it is time to
be more honest about what the risks
really are
so I was living in California when the
debate for legalization was occurring
and I still remember the story on loop
of the little girl who has seizures who
you know it stops her seizures using the
cannabis well I mean that was on Lou
when they were doing the advertising for
that and I think it won a lot of people
over being like oh my gosh like there's
this legitimate medical use for that but
then when it was legalized that was not
the majority of what people were using
it for so I'm wondering when you're
looking at your statistics when you're
looking at use is it just smoking is it
all of the above how did you kind of
sort that out so so great question
there's a lot of confusion out there
which I think advocates have encouraged
and use about the difference between
cannabis THC and CBD so CBD is non
intoxicating and non psychoactive and to
the extent that cannabis has medical
benefits
they're probably in CBD CBD is actually
been approved by the FDA because it can
help treat some childhood seizures
that's true but people who are using
marijuana to get high aren't using CBD
they're using either cannabis that's
very high in THC and usually quite low
in CBD or they're now using more and
more often
pure extracted THC which is basically a
semi-synthetic product that you get by
running butane or carbon dioxide through
cannabis leaves and you suck out the THC
and then you eliminate the butane and
you have this liquid or what some kind
some times called wax or shatter that
people can smoke so those people aren't
they're not interested in seizures
they're just getting high and that's
look that's okay too but let's stop
pretending that most cannabis use is in
any way medical it's not and the
benefits of the drug for most conditions
that it is pushed for are just the
evidence is just not there
hi I am a medicinal cannabis advocate in
activists I'm also the mother of 11 year
old child who's been medicating with CBD
for over three years she had up to sixty
seizures a day no disrespect to the room
but your facts are very very blurred
first of all I recall you saying that
marijuana leads to psychosis also about
the pain and people extracting THC the
higher the dosage of THC for those who
have popped opioids and percocets and
all those things for pain they want to
replace the things that are killing
people 99 people a day with THC even
having a drink opposed to having
cannabis is much healthier the alcohol
will break down the liver where is in
the plant is just the plant lastly it's
not a drug it is a plant there are
different levels to the plant there is
THC THC 80 HCV CBD CBD and and all of
them have medicinal cannabis properties
so on so I mean I thank you for this but
there is no miss guiding what we're
trying to do is educate the world that
there is a better way of replacing
opioid therapy and there is a better way
of 99 people dialing dying daily from
opioids thank you thank you it it seems
essentially that there may be three
arguments in favor of legalizing the use
of marijuana one is that it is valuable
either because of its euphoric or its
other potential medical effects the
other is because it's not harmful and
the third is because it's impossible to
stop its use in any event it seems that
in the case of tobacco we have not
advanced the first or the second
justifications but what we've done is
rely on the third and 2009 Congress
decided finally to regulate the
back o by giving it to the Food and Drug
Administration have you thought about
following a similar policy in the case
of marijuana giving it to the Food and
Drug Administration for them to regulate
um so i think that's i think i think you
outlined the issues pretty clearly and
we can know that this drug is harmful to
some people and and it's especially
complicated because there is a tail risk
problem right and frank psychosis is a
tail risk problem it's not gonna affect
everybody who uses it and we can know
that the downstream risk of violence
although real is small and say you know
what the FDA needs to need to oversee
this i don't think you have to ever want
to go near that but we we could make
them I am Not sure that one of the
things that advocates like to say is
that we have to we have to move to full
legalization that prohibition has
completely failed and and I'm not sure
that that's true I don't see most of
Europe rushing to legalize this drug or
even authorize its use widely for
medical purposes now if we want to say
the harms of arresting people and
possibly messing up their lives you know
outweigh the harms abuse so we're gonna
decriminalize this I that that makes
total sense to me I do I think these are
really complicated political decisions
whether it's the FDA that's involved
whether we decriminalize federally
whether we decide you know we're gonna
spend a billion dollars that you're
warning people about this the way we
warn people about tobacco use and we're
gonna try to drive down use to just two
European levels the u.s. now uses
cannabis about twice as frequently as a
lot of countries in Europe people don't
understand that the outlier in this
debate is the u.s. not because we don't
use this drug but because we do so we
need to figure out we need to we need to
make some rational decisions here but
before we can make those we need to
really talk about what the science says
and that's my book is a medical and
science book not a book about what to do
I do you know I do talk a little bit at
the
and about that but but that would be a
whole nother book in my opinion so do
you see cause for concern in the farm
bill that just legalized CBD no I don't
think I see bees non-intoxicating I want
people to understand the difference
between CBD THC in cannabis
I think the quicker we get there the
better you can go into most grocery
stores now I don't know if it's everyone
must be trying to Washington but
certainly you can go into grocery stores
all over this country and buy CBD CBD
oil CBD tinctures that CBD is
non-intoxicating
so and it doesn't seem to provoke
psychosis so if people want to use it
the way that you st. John's war you know
maybe it's good for some things maybe
it's an expensive placebo for some
things go right ahead you know it's
funny we talk about marijuana as
medicine because it's natural you know
garlic is not a medicine like st. John's
wort is barely a medicine most most
plants even those that have active
medicinal qualities are barely medicine
we get we spend a lot of time not just
in this country but all over the world
trying to figure out how the human body
actually works on the cellular level and
figuring out how we're gonna affect that
and improve that and thinking that
there's one plant whether you know you
smoke good or you eat it as an edible is
his medicine is silly and we don't say
that alcohol is medicine even though
alcohol does have some medicinal
qualities in addition to its negative
qualities it's good it's definitely can
reduce your risk of heart attack and you
know in low doses but we don't pretend
it's medicine I don't know how we got
into pretending that marijuana and THC
are really medicines now CBD is
different but and again CVD does have
these uses but that's not what people
who are using marijuana to get high or
using my question is how much do you
think that the advocacy on both sides of
the debate has impacted the ability to
get good research so so the advocacy by
which I mean the pro
canvas community often says well there
haven't been enough studies because
there are DEA rules against research
I'll just point out that there is now a
center for medical cannabis research at
a state-run university in California
okay there's a there there's a lot of
research on cannabis and on its
potential medical uses and nearly all
that research shows it doesn't have much
in the way of potential medical research
uses what there isn't is a lot of
research and there's a lot of research
on psychosis but even then we could use
more I don't really see that there's
been two balanced advocacy groups here
they're you know they're the the drug
policy Alliance and the Marijuana Policy
Project have have done a really good job
they're really smart and they and they
are singular not singularly focused
because the DPA wants to do other things
but but they've been very focused on
this issue for a long time
and you know on the other side you have
this group called smarter approaches to
marijuana which has a couple million
dollars and it's basically this guy
named Kevin Sabet who you know came out
of the Obama maybe and maybe the maybe
the Bush as well you know drug czars
office and and you know it's kind of
like a voice in the wilderness and and
believe me I don't think that I'm well
aware of the limited impact that my book
is likely to have I don't think it's
going to change the national debate I
think we're very likely to have
legalized cannabis certainly if a
Democrat wins in 2020 that's very likely
I wrote this book so that parents could
talk to their kids in a knowledgeable
way and and teenagers and young adults
who might be worried who might be they
might have smoked and had a bad
experience might have some resource to
say you know what like okay like maybe I
should not do this anymore like I had it
you know I got paranoid and it was bad
and it was weird like let me see if
that's happening to other people you
know that's that's really what my book
is for
so I want to first of all thank you for
bringing this information I'm a parent
of four sons and I also have a family
member with schizophrenia who doesn't
believe that there's anything wrong with
him and in my dealing with this and
learning and researching it seems that
it's it's a cycle that you don't believe
there's anything wrong with you there's
nothing wrong with me
I don't need medicine but yet they turn
to other self-medicating things and so
how do you get research on people with
schizophrenia and there and how do you
get that data for people with
schizophrenia who use marijuana to
self-medicate but yet who reject or a
non-compliant with their meds
well you know there's a there's a place
called King's College London that's you
know there's look there's research in
the u.s. - but but psychiatrists aren't
interested in trying to fix
schizophrenia because they know what a
terrible disease it is and they know how
lousy most the antipsychotics are look
one reason that people don't like taking
antipsychotics is they're very
unpleasant drugs and they have a severe
side effects for a lot of people they
can make you gain weight they can make
you have these strange movement
disorders they're really unpleasant so
so psychiatrists have been have been
monitoring this and they you know one
thing that is I mean I don't think even
the best the strongest can himself can
we disagree that for somebody who's well
controlled schizophrenia is under
control psychotic disorders are under
control if they start using cannabis
again for whatever reason they are very
likely to snap back into psychosis and
quite quickly and you know what are the
other things that I think is not you
know so so I had a big discussion with
the drug policy Alliance and a couple
other people via the marshal project
which is a you know which is a group
that writes about criminal justice
issues in the last 48 hours and and they
said to me well it's irresponsible to
talk about some of this stuff and to me
it's irresponsible not to talk about it
especially when you're talking about
people who have family members who are
especially young people especially young
men especially young men who are who are
you suffering from an early break
and who are psychotic and using canvas
they need to know that the risks of
violence are real you know that I'm not
saying that everybody's gonna get
violent that's not the case but in that
subcategory of people the risks are real
and to pretend that that is not true
does a disservice and a dangerous
disservice to the people who are most
likely to be affected by that violence
so so I you know I be not stigmatizing
people is is valuable but pretending
that the studies don't show what they
show is not valuable by beating y'all
into submission hi JJ rich Reason
Foundation so happy to hear that
elaborated on some things that I think
we're important such as a lot of things
that the marijuana Lobby has pushed
forward that is kind of misinformation
like for example with the relationship
with opioids I've recreated some of
those studies and we add more years of
data the relationships
and coming from reason I think I would
like to see that but seeing that it
falls apart like okay we can't use that
but what I'm more curious about is the
effect of moderate marijuana consumption
on mental illness if you drink a lot of
alcohol all the time your minds gonna
deteriorate yes but if you use it just a
little bit you really shouldn't see any
deterioration of your mind and can we
expect from what I've seen that's pretty
similar if you're if you're using
moderately and you're using as an adult
you know you you're probably fine if you
if you look at the alcohol risk ratios
you know then they're they're really
good data on alcohol risk ratios for
mortality if you drink a drink a day
there's no excess risk essentially and
then it starts to go up you know and if
and even if you drink two drinks a day
there's not much excess risk but once
you get past that you start to see a
real excess risk from alcohol
consumption unfortunate one of the
things in writing this book this
definitely like alerted me to the
interests of even you know moderate
alcohol consumption but but I suspect
it's the same for cannabis you can use
moderately
and you know you're gonna be fine yeah I
think there's a slightly there's that
tail risk of psychosis in some people
you know but that could just hit you but
that's you know it's unlikely and most
of the time even if that does happen
you're just gonna have a bad night and
you might wind up in the ER you're not
gonna do anything terrible to anybody
but but yeah I would agree with that and
I do think you know I think Malcolm
Gladwell in his in his piece last week
which drew a little bit on the book he
talks about this issue what do you do
with something that most people using
most of the time it's just you know it's
a fun night for them but some people
have a terrible outcome and and that's a
that's a tough question societally sure
thanks me again so I just wanna ask you
quickly about in the third section of
your book which is your associate at the
red tide the rise of violent crime
associated you're talking to aggravated
assault and murder specifically the
association with legalization and your
evidence has relied primarily upon this
legalization states saw a 35 percent
increase in violent crime compared to
20% increase nationwide yes so I want to
sort of ask how committed you are to
that analysis there's been a lot of
pushback against and I actually if you
go look at mr. data on the association
between frequency of marijuana use and
violent crime there's no correlation at
state between states so I think it's a
really good question and the truth is I
also you know if I'm gonna criticize
Baku burr for using state-level data on
the opioid stuff I can certainly face
the same criticism um my point and I
think it's been a little bit
intentionally lost by the Abbas
community is not that this has been
proven it is not proven yet I don't
think I mean I don't think anybody could
say pants crime is really multifactorial
what I do think is that advocates need
to stop saying incorrectly that that
cannabis use or that legalizing cannabis
is going to lower violent crime we now
have a pretty robust data set saying
that's not true now maybe in five years
we'll see that violent crime went down
and
California and you know that this thing
whatever happened in Colorado and
whatever happened in Washington was a
blip and then they'll be able to say you
know what look we were right Berenson's
an idiot fine you know what I would be
happy if that happens because it would
mean that fewer people are getting
killed
and violently assaulted right now the
data points one way and you can explain
it away and you can say that you know
what this is a statistical anomaly or if
we synthesized this mock Colorado we
when compared to the real color that's
all true
but what is not true is that violent
crime is decreasing and I can point you
to specific cases where cannabis use
clearly led to a bad outcome so so
that's where I am I I with you if you
ask me am I committed to this I'd say
you know it's you know the old joke
about the the ham and egg sandwich the
the chicken is interested in the pig is
committed I'm the chicken I'm interested
in this and what I don't like is that
people are dismissing it out of hand
because I think there's too much data
that all points the same way and there's
a biologically plausible theory which is
canvas leads to psychosis psychosis
produces a measurable increase in the
risk of violence I like this is a quick
wrap-up question for you in given what
you've learned and the bulk in our
discussion here which seems suggests
there's a lot of unknowns
well would you advise say state
legislatures or governors who are seeing
this patchwork policy coming across
their country I would say two things one
you know the the guinea-pig you don't
know you don't have to legalize right
now why don't you wait for some more
data and - if you're gonna legalize for
medical use
once you're legalized for pain once you
say that this treats pain basically
you've backed or legalize recreational
because that is quite clear because
anybody can go to a doctor and say I
have pain we all have pain at some point
and get this authorization card and then
buy so if you're gonna legalize for
medical use it should be strict strict
medical use which is conditions that
that cannabis or THC have actually been
shown to treat and that's very few the
advocacy community
doesn't want that because they know how
limited the market is in that case so so
those are the two things I would say you
know there's no rule that says you have
to do this you're not really missing out
on that much tax revenue even in
Colorado which is the state that where
it's the biggest market sort of relative
to the size of the population it's less
than 1% of the state budget so so so you
know we have this we have this you know
laboratory of democracy in the states
let other states be the laboratory well
thank you all I I enjoyed the questions
thank you for having
[Applause]